welcome back everyone to episode number
nine of the speedrun I'm currently rated
778 and as usual I'm going to try and
show no mercy and try and just provide a
lot of lessons during the course of this
episode so let's hop into a 10-minute
game and I imagine I'll play good number
of games this episode playing parinda
rated
825 and so far throughout this uh the
speedrun I've been sticking with the
same opening repertoire and my opponents
are not failing to bring out their Queen
early um usually we don't see Queen F3
on move two usually we see either Queen
H5 uh going for the more traditional
Scholar's mate or Bishop C4 followed by
Queen H5 or queen
F3 um in this case I don't mind just
developing and once the bishop comes to
C4 I will
not get checkmated I'm obstructing the
queen from attacking
F7 uh but my opponent playing quickly
maybe has played this position before C3
is a very fine move because it does
prevent me from playing Knight
D4 but I think the strategy here is just
to Castle King side as quickly as
possible and I'll start with Bishop
C5 which not only prepares castling but
also discourages black from or
discourages white from playing Pawn
D4 uh so white plays D3 and this does
prepare Bishop to
G5 and I guess it's a question here like
do I want
to prevent Bishop G5 with a move like
H6 uh cuz I could Castle could play
D6 there are a few
options but I kind of like the idea of
playing H6 even though some sometimes
this is not the best use of time in the
opening uh I do deprive white of the
most active Square for the
bishop and I'm just trying to be solid
would like to
Castle uh probably right
now and this way my knight is no longer
pinned to the F Pawn because my Rook is
now helping defend as
well so white being very aggressive we
see Pawn
D4 which sometimes this move can
be a like an effective Gambit of sorts
uh in this case I have three
attackers and there's only one Pawn
defending D4 so I think I'm more than
happy to
take uh and there's cases where
sometimes white gambits to play
E5 but I'm covering E5 I'm going to just
take another pawn and accept my early
holiday presence uh no mercy that's a
free
Queen So within just nine moves we see
my
opponent giving away a lot of pieces uh
my Bishop is hanging now yeah I was
going to say if white takes the bishop I
have the move Queen
E7 and really just showing no mercy this
is uh kind of downward spiraling for
white um now it is a question do I want
to take the Knight I think a lot of
players would just snatch the Knight
immediately I do have the move here Rook
E8 which
I think I'm more inclined to
play because I'm I'm leaving the Knight
attacked but I'm more interested in just
checkmating the
king and there's not too many moves here
for white that prevent the checkmates uh
castling is probably the best try but
then I'll have the option which Knight
to take so life is very good here just
made a cup of tea
too
um yeah let's take this
Knight I have the battery on
eile maybe there are some cases where I
can generate some back rank ideas
against the
king uh might be hard to do
with especially with the bishop here
preventing Knight
[Music]
D2 we see Bishop F4 and I think it's an
important lesson like when you're
completely winning out of the opening
you just want to still be patient and
focus on principles not give away
anything um really just try and clamp
down on the
opponent and here I'm just attacking the
Knight I was going to say that if white
were to play either Rook to E1 I'll be
happy to take and then uh likely get a
mate on the back
rank uh here the pawn is attacked let's
play
D3 I could have traded which would have
been completely fine but I like the
prospect of of pushing uh now I do have
to see the Knight is attacking the queen
um sometimes it's easy to miss these
backward Knight
moves but I don't mind taking another uh
another free
thing
and yeah multiple things hanging in
White's
position yeah that game was basically an
all you can eat buffet um I really did
not slow down um but as we see sometimes
this is just what it takes to win at
this level um just a matter of following
opening principles controlling the
center waiting for the opponent to in
this case be generous and yeah starting
with D4 and then uh basically all
everything that happened it was uh it
was just a one-sided game so let's move
on uh I'll do another 10-minute game
maybe one game away from getting to 800
I'll play E4 playing F
15 and yeah with the openings here just
trying to demonstrate like proper
opening principles not developing the
queen
early and not even going for Knight G5
um at some point during the series I'll
probably play more attempted like Fri
liver attack but I'm going to play the
most solid move here Pawn D3 uh
completing this Pawn chain
getting ready to activate this
bishop uh now in this position I'll
start with Knight to
C3 and there is a plan here to play
Bishop G5 combined with Knight
D5 and actually when I was uh about 8
years old like around the age of this
picture um this was one of the main
openings I liked to play for white and
this is one of the earliest strategies I
remember learning is pinning the
kingside Knight and then bringing in
this Knight into the center to apply
more pressure to this pinned Knight on
F6 and this is actually already pretty
unpleasant for black to deal
with because the bishop can't really
block can't move backwards to E7 with a
pawn committed to
D6 and there's not a great way to add
another Defender to the
Knight so we see black actually maybe
trying to give me a taste of my own
medicine uh maybe preparing this move KN
D4 uh but with especially being white
and having extra Tempo I have time to to
deal with
this and there's a few options here like
I could start by
taking like take either way and Force
black to double the pawns on the king
side I I'm a bit more inclined to just
leave the pin uh cuz this Knight is not
really going
anywhere and I like this move Pawn to
C3 which very simply prevents Knight
D4 and it's a very nice Square for the
pawn because it restricts uh both of
these pieces and here I'll take back
with the
queen and I think Bishop takes F3 was
actually a pretty big mistake even
though it was already difficult uh for
black to play now I have another
attacker there's now three attackers
against the
Knight which is still pinned to the
queen there's only two
Defenders so looks like next move I'll
be guaranteed to win
material um but not only that I think
it's very likely I'll have a mating
attack within just a few
moves if we imagine I'm able to take
let's say with the Knight and then take
and then take I'll already be
threatening checkmates along the G
file so opponent plays kind of a random
move um if I want to I could play B4 and
trap the
bishop but there's bigger fish to catch
in this
position I'm going to go with the plan I
was calculating um just now taking with
a bishop yeah I'm threatening check made
in one and I'm threatening to take the
queen Black's best move is probably to
take the bishop res signing is also uh
perhaps a reasonable option there and we
see another like pretty one-sided game
um I mean this game was I think
definitely higher quality than the first
game and just offers a very nice example
of this middle game plan like when the
opponent copies me from early on I
didn't really have to Castle here I was
able to go for the immediate um attack
against the pinned Knight and it's a
very common principle in chest when
you're pinning a piece usually you don't
want to immediately take the piece you
want to just apply pressure to the
pinned
piece and yeah opponent made made made
life a bit easier with Bishop takes
F3 now before I move on to the next game
I should provide a lesson for my
opponent um like in this position I
think black had to be very very careful
and the best move was probably to move
back even though it's passive it
diffuses a pin so Knight D5 is no longer
as effective because black has the
Knight
defended um another alternative here for
black is to wait before castling uh like
the move I would have played here is
Pawn
D6 and there's a nice little tip here I
can give that let's say you're playing
black and your opponent plays Bishop G5
preparing this uh because Black's not
casting
there's a nice approach to play H6 let's
say white maintains a pin with Bishop
H4 then black can actually get away with
playing
G5
and because black has not committed the
king it's completely okay to expand on
the king side uh it's not good for white
to take even though this kind of looks
interesting uh black will have enough
ways to get initiative also Rook G6
coming to defend the Knight so very like
what would happen here is Bishop G3 and
then the plan for black would be to
develop the queen side and then
eventually Castle on the queen side and
then try and attack later on the king
side so just a short opening lesson but
hopefully this provides some value maybe
to my opponent who could be watching
this in the future but really to anyone
who uh who plays a King's Pawn opening
as black and maybe doesn't know how to
deal with this
immediate um strategy from White it's
good to sometimes lay casting to go for
the early
expansion so with that uh let's move on
to the third game of this episode
playing T Moine and I have officially
broken
800 so I think I'm due for a a profile
picture update for at least the next
episode and we'll repeat the same
opening it would be nice to get the same
strategy a couple games in a row uh but
here we see my opponent very quickly
preventing Bishop G5 preventing Knight
G5 so I'll have to use a different
strategy here and I'm going to start
with Knight C3 again and perhaps we'll
see just a different way of playing such
a
position expecting my opponent to play
Bishop
C5 should also note that I think this is
the highest rated opponent I've played
so far in the
series and as I
progress uh the games will definitely
get just higher quality and hopefully
there will be just deeper lessons to to
learn from these games my opponents
won't be blundering so easily so we see
Bishop B4 uh pinning the Knight now this
move isn't so annoying because I can I
can now happily Castle
and I really don't mind if black takes
because then I would strengthen the
center and have the bishop pair uh but
we see
D5 and with D5 I think my opponent maybe
miscounted there's two Defenders and
three
attackers uh now it's a question what I
want to take
with I think almost certainly I want to
take with the Knight just to make sure
that black can't throw in Bishop takes
Knight so yeah let's snag a free
pawn it will be interesting though if we
see my opponent maybe go for Bishop G4
and then potentially Knight
D4 as uh we saw in the previous game um
if my opponent were to play Bishop G4 I
would have happily played C3 kick the
bishop and prevent Knight
D4 but now there's a big focal point on
D5 black has three attackers I have only
two
Defenders
so in a spot like this I think it makes
sense to trade like I won a pawn I don't
mind trading Knights this comes with
check allows me to trade Bishop's next
move and here I'm really just going for
the the simple and solid approach like
we clarify the position a little bit all
complete
development this is the most logical
most Central Square for the bishop
and we'll just see how black chooses to
progress and we are approaching the
middle
game uh we see Knight D4 I think this is
another instance of my opponent just not
realizing the number of attackers and
Defenders I have two attackers black has
one Defender it is a question do I want
to take with the Knight or the
bishop honestly I think both moves are
fine it's probably not something to
overthink um I'm going to take with the
bishop just because after I after my
oppent takes back I take with Knight I
hit the queen so this gives me some nice
initiative I think very likely my knight
will be coming to
F5 although if I play Knight
F5 black
could attempt to capture on
B2
I'm calculating Queen takes B2 Rook
[Music]
B1 another option is to play
C3 which defends and
attacks I like
C3 even though maybe I'm chasing the
bishop to a more centralized
Square uh it's a very solid setup for
the pawns I reinforce the
Knight if Bishop D6 black would be
threatening eight and then I would have
either played Knight F3 or
F4 um here I definitely don't want to
play F4 because that allows Bishop takes
D4 and black would then win back a
pawn so probably a question where to
move the
Knight Knight F5 Knight
F3 there's also Queen A4 cheack to
consider
go for Knight
F3 it's very stable move hitting the
queen and nice thing about getting the
Knight away from D4 is I'm making way
for the pawn ideally I'd just like the
two Pawns in the
center yeah I'll continue here with Pawn
D4 I was going to say that there's cases
where if I allow Queen takes
E4 then rookie E1 would be a pin along
the E
file um now Bishop D6 is not threatening
mates because my knight defends so I'm
debating here like E5 is actually a
really nice looking move I could also
play Queen D2 and just try and head
towards an end
game probably not a moment I want to
spend too long
on so I think Queen D2 makes
sense this does set up the Trap Queen E4
Rook E1 oh no my
Pawn Yeah the Knight is very important
defending the queen and the M threat
Queen F6 now allows E5 to come with a
fork let's take with Pawn keeping the
initiative hitting the
queen so I've gone up a bit of material
up a knight and a pawn and from this
position I would really like to
prevent black from
cing might be hard to do
[Music]
though like there's a move here
that I don't think too many beginners
would play like I think a lot of people
would play either Rook a D1 maybe Rook
fe1 get the Rooks
involved but I really like the idea of
playing Pawn E6 just
being
uh immediately
confrontational and the point is not
only I'm trying to open the E file like
if Queen takes E6 I'll have Rook
E1 but another point is if the pawn
takes back then I have Knight E5
attacking the queen and
preparing Queen to
D7 and this is what we call a clearance
idea maybe not necessarily a clearance
tactic but I'm simply clearing the
square for the Knight also trying to
clear the file to exploit the
king and the nice thing about playing
Knight E5 is I attack the queen I
threaten Queen D7 but I'm also taking
away F7 from The Black
Queen
so yeah not easy for black to defend
against everything there and now this is
force Checkmate Queen F7 coming
next no
mercy and another win I think that was a
nice instructive
game uh saw some nice ideas there
towards the end of course with giving
away the
ewn and my opponent made definitely a
handful of like very clear
mistakes uh first of all playing D5 just
giving free material and they were very
similar types of mistakes later playing
Knight D4 just not realizing that the
square was better controlled by white
than by black so sometimes this is a
very
common uh common Pitfall for players
especially at the sub 1000 ELO is just
giving away from free material when it's
not necessary and one of the the simple
secrets to passing
1,000 is simply by minimizing cases like
this even when you give away free pawns
they can definitely add up over the
course of a game so
yeah instead of playing a move like D5
here if my opponent played D6 it would
have been um probably a much harder
battle and yeah I was going to say that
if we saw a D6 then like maybe I would
play H3 maybe I would play something
like Knight D5 to pressure the bishop
and prepare C3 there are definitely some
possibilities for white to continue
developing so um let's do at least one
more just checking my recording here
looks like everything is
smooth yeah let's go
again playing ozgar
66 my opponent is on the cusp of
breaking
900 will try and ruin their dreams in
this game um I do want to note that with
every opponent I play uh their ratings
will be refunded this is an authorized
speedrun account on chest
uh now we see the filor defense which is
Pawn
D6 and it's a slightly more passive
approach because black is locking in
their own
Bishop we see Bishop
G4 I'm actually trying to
remember some like vague memory of some
Nifty traps here whenever the bishop
comes to G4 you do want to consider
ideas of Bishop takes F7 or Knight takes
E5
neither move really works here um Bishop
takes F7 King takes Knight
G5 almost looks good but allows Queen
takes
G5 so I think I'm better off just
developing seeing what black is up
to okay we see the trade I'll take with
Queen threatening
matate um this is one case where I was
provoked to bring out my queen early but
it's a perfectly fine Square especially
given that black is
underdeveloped uh now my opponent is
defending against the
threat the first move that comes to mind
here is Knight
D5 which I don't know if Knight D5 is
actually so effective because it does
allow black to play Queen
D7 and I'm dreaming of ideas of like
Bishop B5 and queen takes B5 and Knight
takes E7 but the problem with that
variation if we imagine the bishop comes
to
B5 black would have
C6 and I don't want to fall into like
just playing hope chess and hoping my
opponent
blunders where I'm just playing like
suboptimal
moves um now it's very possible Knight
D5 is still good and centralizes a
knight and keeps
initiative I'm not really seeing the
followup after like Queen D7 and then
preparing
Pawn
C6 so I think I would rather just keep
it simple like focus on the development
of my final minor piece and we see C6
anyway so let's just focus on
developing no need to go too crazy too
soon Knight
F6 and the nice thing about this
position for me is I'm like nearly fully
developed black is a bit slow because a
queen is blocking the bishop which
blocks a
king so there's a few options here uh
one obvious option is to move the bishop
to pin the
Knight but not sure how effective that
is because like if Bishop here and black
plays
H6 I'm not so inclined to take and just
trade I think that would make life
easier for black and if I move back then
maybe black expands with
G5 so I think I'm much happier just
playing Bishop
E3 and the strategy behind this move is
to focus in the center and ideally get
in the move Pawn
D4 and the common principle is when the
opponent is very slow to develop and
slow to Castle usually you want to look
for Pawn breaks in the center that will
open up the position like mainly open
the files or just open lines for the
minor pieces and here we see the The
Bishop's already coming to
life Black's plays C5 which hits the
bishop on
D4 uh but the drawback of this move is
the pawn can't move backwards and these
squares are now available for my knight
or potentially
Bishop so A Move Like You A Move Like
Knight D5 is
already a possible
consideration and Bishop takes F6
followed by Knight D5 also looks very
attractive I'm taking time here to uh to
consider the options I think there's a
lot of good options here like taking or
Bishop E3 are probably the the two most
normal
moves I'm going to play a move here
which is based on basically a three move
calculation and starting with Knight D5
the idea is I'm attacking the queen
and I'm trying to provoke black to take
so I can open the E file and if I can
get this Pawn off the E file then
there's going to be potential to win the
queen uh speaking of winning the queen I
can win it right away not sure if my
opponent just Overlook that or maybe
figure they're getting some
material uh now it's a queen for two
knights so very good trade for white and
I definitely want to try and keep my
foot on the gas here I mean a move like
Rook D1 is very
natural I see that the B7 Pawn is
undefended so the move that comes to
mind is
E5 and if black takes then I can take
the pawn and trap The
Rook so that looks really really
nice not to mention the Knight is pinned
to the F Pawn
so yeah sometimes like after the first
mistake it can very easily kind of
snowball
into just a even worse position for
black I'm going to keep snagging free
pawns just want to make sure I don't
Mouse slip or or blunder the
queen but this is a very difficult
position to come back from for
black um Brook does attack the
bishop the simple move here would be
Bishop to
B3
but the more energetic move would be I
like this move Bishop to
B5 CU I leave the pawn attacked but I'm
threatening something a bit more
valuable and the Knight is essentially
pinned to the bishop and now the Rook is
tied down to defending the Knight so uh
yeah Rook d8 was probably the best move
there but
now what to do so I'm up
material I could trade if I want but I
don't think there's any reason to trade
right
away I think the simplest strategy in
this position is to
realize I have a couple past pawns on
the queen
side and I might as well push them
especially this a pawn it's supported by
the rook and once my queen gets out of
the
way let's say
queen queen C7 or queen
B7 couple op options here I think both
moves are perfectly fine I'll play Queen
C7 attacking The
Rook now this freeze away for the pawn
so and before pawn moves away from
making another
queen I think black's best try here
would be Bishop B6 to attack the queen
and defend the Rook through x-ray vision
with Bishop
E7 I'm happy to to keep
pushing I have noticed this a lot in
like lower level games of players
sometimes struggling to convert the
material
advantage and like sometimes the
simplest thing is just to look for your
past pawns and push them and it can very
very often end the game much more
quickly so here I want to of course make
sure that I'm not hanging my queen also
I have to watch out for my time too I've
spent a lot of time trying to explain
things in
depth
um yeah I'm going to play a move here
which just simplifies I think it's
completely
fine giving the queen to get a knight
and Rook off the board even though
that's
technically um a more favorable trade
for
black it just simplifies a position a
lot
and now this should be an easier
approach although black is is going to
resist Maybe
let's keep
pushing yeah I'm not making another
queen right away and I am possibly
losing this Pawn uh now it turns out
this Pawn was actually a bit poisonous
because I have this move Bishop to
F5 it's not that black had too many
other like great looking options but now
I'm not only hitting the Knight I'm
taking away the Square from the king so
I'm setting up the back ring
Checkmate opponent does defend against
the
mate but now I'm up couple Rooks and a
bishop these pawns are not going to be
enough so we'll see if my opponent uh
chooses to fight
here oh game abandoned
okay so again my opponent will be
refunded they um their rating points
hopefully they can break 900 at some
point soon but anyway uh I think that
was a pretty smooth game it stemmed from
a somewhat passive opening from black uh
usually it's not a great idea to trade
off the bishop so early because it
really just helped me
activate and um yeah there's cases where
you should be happy just getting your
queen out and have it apply pressure to
the opponent's position I think one of
the one of the main takeaways
uh going into the middle game here was
just to look for the way to open the
center and this allowed me to get a
pretty big Advantage
from from early on especially when my
opponent plundered the queen uh the one
thing I want to show was if my opponent
were to
take at first it looks like I'm losing
material but the whole idea was to win
the queen on E5 this would be a really
nice pin so if we
entered this position then yeah black is
under major pressure because Rook E1 is
very hard to deal with probably the
queen would have to move I still play
Rook E1 and yeah Bishop E7 would allow
Bishop takes
G7 so yeah pretty difficult position for
black to play but anyway I think uh
there were a lot of nice instructive
games from this episode hope you learned
a thing or two uh do stay tuned for more
if you have questions or comments as
usual leave leave them below I look
forward to reading them and stay tuned
for another episode see you guys soon